this morning there is growing outrage
over a violent arrest of a black man in
a memphis suburb cell phone video the
incident we have to tell you is
disturbing to see oakland tennessee
police officers are accused of racial
profiling and excessive use of force in
the arrest of brandon callaway they
chased him through the family home and
photos taken after the arrest show the
suspect bleeding from his head now this
all happened after an alleged traffic
violation
daniel backus has the story including
callaway's reaction donna good morning
to you
good morning to you gail in an affidavit
police say instead of pulling over for
allegedly rolling through a stop sign
callaway then drove to his family's home
with officers in pursuit callaway then
ran inside the home and that's right
around the time when this recording
taken by his girlfriend begins again we
must warn you this video is graphic
this video shows the moment oakland
tennessee police officers entered the
family home of 25 year old brandon
calloway
the officers can be seen chasing
callaway from room to room one swinging
up a ton at him then a stun gun is
deployed but police say it had no effect
why are you chasing him and hitting him
he has no weapon
galloway is then restrained on the
ground when an officer appears to step
on his head or neck
police say callaway failed to stop at a
stop sign and drove 32 in a 20 miles per
hour zone and instead of stopping for
police he drove about half a mile to his
family's home according to the police
report callaway started running into the
house while reaching into his pockets
photos taken by callaway's girlfriend
showing him bloodied in the street after
being detained have caused outrage
online they've been viewed hundreds of
thousands of times and have generated
almost as many comments
just watching the videos like
this is like a bad dream callaway is a
college grad and entrepreneur who says
he was completing a doordash delivery
the incident happened last weekend and
callaway says he's still suffering from
head and vision problems you see this
stuff happen all the time and the fact
that it happened to me is really mind
blowing his trauma
is a message to the world
this is the wrong way to do things he
didn't ask for the officers to
use this amount of force i'm glad that
i'm alive like blessed but i wouldn't
want any like i don't know how people
live with this
the department says callaway was cleared
by medics before he was taken into
custody he is facing several charges
which include evading arrest and
disorderly conduct police have not
released any further details and told
our memphis affiliate the case has been
officially turned over to the county
district attorney's office the tennessee
bureau of investigation is also
investigating nate
tanya thank you
i understand that not stopping for a
stop sign um is something that a police
officer can pull you over for yeah but
the force
that's why so many people are asking the
question why
i also understand
certainly if you're a person of color
too and you're being chased by a police
officer you're very frightened so you
run into your own home you're told that
he's not armed police don't necessarily
believe that but there
and they don't know that but there seems
like there had to be a better way to
handle that than what they did raises
the questions of tactics because if a
person runs you are interested in
catching them and wondering why they're
running but you can stop outside the
house and gather yourself figure out the
situation and and then make an arrest
yeah i would think but this is this goes
to training and tactics and i'd be
interested i wish i wish officers
themselves talked more publicly instead
of standing behind unions or or spokes
people from departments because about
what they're taught the general public
wants to know what the thinking is when
they see something like this because
they otherwise don't understand right
difference between force and excessive
force yeah there's a way that so many
ways they could have handled that just
glad that mr calloway is still alive
today to tell the story that's right